did you know that the stupidest bait in
the history of pro CSO was the result of
a tech issue all right ESL Pro League
season 14 it's the group stage between
Forza and OG they load into the 15th
round and then all of a sudden Al maer's
game freezes what is going on he can't
turn he can't move he's just acting as a
Decoy for his teammates right now now
this was a known bug in CS your screen
would freeze but the player could
actually still move in game my screen
just froze but I'm moving so they're
exting out of RAM and aler basically is
just like all right guys I'm going to
run out just bait me and the craziest
thing is that it
works the dude is a literal bot he's a
literal bot just running out of ramp
look at the laugh dude now his teammate
Jerry actually confirmed on Twitter that
he could move in game it was just a
screen that froze see kids you can be a
literal bot swinging out of Mirage ramp
and still win the round